WE HAVE REACHED THE TOP,
IT'S TAKING A WHILE,
40 NAMES. WE COUNTED THEM
DOWN. CHRIS DOES IT EVERY
YEAR AND WE
ARE ONCE AGAIN FOR THE SECOND
STRAIGHT YEAR.
PATRICK MAHOMES THE BEST
QUARTERBACK
CURRENTLY IN THE NFL.
NOT A SURPRISE.
WE KNEW FROM THE MOMENT HE
BECAME THE STARTER IN 2018.
THIS GUY WAS SPECIAL, HE'S GOT
SKILLS. WE HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE
SKILLS, THAT MAYBE WILL BE
REPLICATED
SOME DAY. CHRIS MAYBE NOT TAKE
US THROUGH SOME OF WHAT YOU'VE
SEEN FROM IT. WELL, I MEAN,
I MEAN, COME ON.
SKILLS ARE IN,
IT'S MAYBE THE MOST TALENTED
THROWER WE'VE EVER SEEN AS FAR
AS LIKE, DIVERSITY AT THROWS
THAT ONE LIKE SIDEARM. LIKE
WHAT DOES THAT A SHORTSTOP
THROW? THIS ONE.
LIKE GET THE HELL OUT OF HERE.
TWO FEET OFF THE GROUND.
55 FEET GUYS BUT
55 YARDS GUYS. BARELY
OPEN. I MEAN HE THROWS
THAT
57. 58 YARDS WITH NO FEET ON
THE GROUND. JUMPING UP TO
ABSORB A HIT AND THROWS A
PERFECTLY THIS STUFF ON THE
RUN. I MEAN, HE'S
AGAIN HIM AND JOSH ALVIN TO
THE BEST SCRAMBLING
QUARTERBACKS IN THE LEAGUE.
RIGHT NOW MAHOMES IS NUMBER
ONE, THERE'S NOBODY BETTER AT
GETTING OUT OF THE POCKET.
MANIPULATING COVERAGES. YOU
CAN'T STOP. AND THIS LIKE
WHAT? OH WAIT I'M GONNA MAKE A
JUMP THROW. OH WAIT, I'M GONNA
RUN.
OH WAIT. I'LL THROW
INSIDE ARM BACK ACROSS MY
BODY
BODY LIKE SIDE ON.
BACK ACROSS HIS BODY TO THE
UNNATURAL
SIDE.
THAT'S WHERE WE'VE NEVER SEEN
STUFF LIKE THIS. HE DOES MORE
THINGS WHERE YOU SAY, NO, NO,
NO, NO, OKAY, FINE
THAN ANYBODY EVER THIS RIGHT
HERE, GOING BACK TO THE JOSH
ALAN POINT BEFORE, HE KNOWS
HE'S HOT. HE KNOWS HE
HAS AN EXTRA GUY THAT'S NOT
BLOCKED. HE GOES SCREW THE
FOUR AND FIVE YARD
ROUND. I'LL FADE AWAY. I COULD
SCORCH THIS DEFENSE FOR MORE
THAN JUST THE HOT ROUTE 5
YARDS, I CAN THROW A
55-YARD HER OFF MY BACK FOOT.
IT DOESN'T MATTER AND
THE GUY
YOU SEE THERE. HE'S NOT EVEN
OPEN. WHEN HE'S GEARING UP TO
THROW IT. HE JUST GOES ALL. I
KNOW HE'S FAST AND I KNOW I
CAN THROW IT FAR ENOUGH, THAT
IT'LL OUTRUN THE COVERAGE. I
MEAN,
REALLY, THERE'S NOTHING.
REALLY NOT A LOT OF NEGATIVE.
YOU CAN SAY ABOUT THIS GUY.
HE'S AS YOU'VE SAID MANY
A TIMES, THE TALENTS IS GOOD
AS ANYBODY WE'VE EVER SEEN IN
THE HISTORY OF THE SPORT AND
WE'VE NEVER SEEN ANYBODY COME
INTO THE LEAGUE AND TAKE THE
LEAGUE BY STORM. THE WAY HE
HAS.
AND HE'S STILL NOT EVEN IN THE
FRONT O OF HIS PRIME,
RIGHT? IF HE RETAINS HIS
PHYSICAL ABILITIES. IF HE
DOESN'T GET
BEATEN DOWN AND BANGED UP,
YOU KNOW, WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR. ALL THE RUNNING
AROUND, WHAT IT DID TO THE
TOE BUT IF HE CAN KEEP HIS
PHYSICAL ABILITIES AS HIS
BRAIN
CONTINUES TO PROCESS
TO SEE
THE DIFFERENT LOOKS
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S THERE.
WHAT'S NOT THERE. AND HE GETS
TO THE POINT WHERE HE'S LIKE A
TOM BRADY OR PEYTON MANNING
AND HE WALKS
IT'S TO THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE
AND THERE'S NOTHING THAT HE
SEES THAT HE HASN'T SEEN
BEFORE
MY GOD. I LOOK, I
HEY, HE ALREADY SHOULD HAVE
TWO SUPER BOWL RINGS.
YOU COULD ARGUE THAT MAYBE
HE'D EVEN HAVE THREE IF THEY
WIN THAT COIN TOSS AND
IN
TO START OVER TIME IN THE
2018, AFC CHAMPIONSHIP GAME.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY HE'S
GOING TO HAVE. I DON'T KNOW
THAT HE'S GOING TO COME CLOSE
TO CATCHING TOM BRADY BUT HE'S
THE GUY RIGHT NOW
IN THE NFL
THAT IF BRADY'S WORRIED ABOUT
ANYBODY
CATCHING
OR
EIGHT OR WHATEVER ENDS UP WITH
MAHOMES IS THE ONE TO WORRY.
YEAH.
AND NO DOUBT ABOUT IT,
I DON'T KNOW EITHER. I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU'LL BE ABLE TO PLAY
AS LONG AS BRADY TO WHAT YOU
MENTIONED.
IT'S A DIFFERENT BRAND OF
FOOTBALL.
NOT EVERYBODY GETS BILL.
BELICHICK SYSTEM
OFFENSE OF LINE,
NINE MILLION WAYS TO GET THE
BALL OUT OF YOUR HANDS,
YOU KNOW, QUICKLY,
OH, THE BEST PASS PROTECTION,
ALL OF THAT STUFF. THE THAT
SAYS THINGS THAT BRADY HAS
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF MAHOMES HAS
TO DO IT A LITTLE BIT MORE,
BUT THIS PHYSICAL ABILITY,
YOU KNOW.
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD OFFENSE.
THEY'VE CERTAINLY
SURROUNDING BY TALENT. I DON'T
SIT THERE AND GO. OH, IT'S
LIKE THE MOST AMAZING
OFFENSE IN FOOTBALL. THERE'S
BETTER SCHEMES OUT THERE AS
WE SAW WITH THE SUPER BOWL.
I MEAN, THERE WAS NO ANSWERS
TO DEEP ZONE COVERAGE TO THROW
THE BALL UNDERNEATH AND GO
WAIT, THEY'RE PLAYING US THAT
WAY.
ALL RIGHT,
AND OUR TIGHT END EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE GOING TO SEND EVERYBODY
DEEP AND WE USUALLY JUST
LIKE WE DO THAT. WHEN WE WANT
TO THROW A SHORT, WE SEND
EVERYBODY DEEP AND THEN WE
HAVE TRAVIS KELCE, JUST WORK
ON SOME GUY UNDERNEATH
WELL. THEY
COULDN'T DO THAT AGAINST DEVON
WHITE AND THAT GROUP THEY
GOT TO HAVE MORE ANSWERS THAT
WAY. SO
YEAH MAHOMES. HE'S LIKE YOU
SAID THE ONLY AREA WHERE YOU
GO. COULD HE GET A LITTLE BIT?
BETTER
IS? YEAH. MAYBE THERE IS SOME
PLAYS THERE LEFT TO BE HAD,
YOU KNOW AND MOMENTS. COULD HE
BE A HAIR GREEDY?
SURE.
CERTAINLY.
BUT IT'S JUST, IT'S
NITPICKING. I MEAN HE REALLY
HAS AN INCREDIBLE FEEL FOR THE
GAME AND WHAT'S AMAZING
AGAIN?
LIKE AARON RODGERS
WERE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF THE
GREATEST
GUNSLINGERS AND
HISTORY OF THE SPORT
AND THEY TAKE CARE OF THE
FOOTBALL.
YOU KNOW, THAT'S THE OTHER
THING TOO.
IT'S IT'S IT'S SIX
INTERCEPTIONS
YOU KNOW IT'S HEY WE KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH OF A RUNNING
GAME, WE DROP BACK TO THROW
THE BALL ALL THE TIME,
YOU KNOW? AND HONESTLY, I'LL
SAY THIS, TOO. HE THREW FOR
66 PERCENT LAST YEAR. MIKE
66,
OH, NO. YOU KNOW, IF YOU DON'T
THROW FOR 70%, I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE A GOOD QUARTERBACK IN
THE NFL ANYMORE, I
LOVE THAT HE THREW FOR
66%. I THOUGHT HE WAS A LITTLE
BIT MORE AGGRESSIVE LAST YEAR.
YOU KNOW?
NO STRESS DEFENSE IS OUT. THAT
WAY MORE TO AND REALLY IF
HE PLAYED THAT LAST GAME OF
THE YEAR, WHO KNOWS? HE
PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
5,000 YARDS,
BUT MAN JUST SUPERSTAR AND
ONLY GETTING BETTER.
I'M VERY CURIOUS TO SEE.
HOW GOOD HE WILL BE WHEN THE
TIME COMES THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE
TRAVIS KELCE AND OR TYREE
KILL. I'M VERY CURIOUS ABOUT
THAT RIGHT. CAN HE MAKE
CHICKEN SALAD OUT OF LESSER
RECEIVERS NOW
MEANWHILE
FRED VEATCH THE GUY WHO
DISCOVERED
MAHOMES IS IN CHARGE OF THE
FRONT OFFICE AND WILL BE
CHARGED WITH CONSTANTLY
RELOADING THE CANNON AND
FINDING THE NEXT TRAVIS KELCE
FINDING THE NEXT
TYREE KILL, BUT
CAN MAHOMES CARRY A TEAM
THAT DOESN'T HAVE
AN
ALL ARRAY OF WEAPONS AND
ALSO AT SOME
POINT
IF MAHOMES IS PLAYING AND
ANDY, REID, ISN'T THE COACH.
HOW WILL THAT AFFECT SURE?
PAT MAHOMES HOW MUCH OF
MAHOMES OF OF
AT TEXAS TECH? ONE OF THE
REASON WE DIDN'T SEE MY HOME'S
COMING,
IS THERE WERE A LOT OF FLAWS
RIGHT IN THE GAME AT TEXAS
TECH
AND
AND COACHING
OR LACK THEREOF IS WHAT'S
GOING TO INFLUENCE WHETHER TO
WHAT EXTENT YOU OVERCOME,
THOS
STAKES. AND
ANDY REID HAS DONE A GOOD JOB
OF MAKING MAHOMES AWARE
CONSTANTLY AND REPEATEDLY OF
THE THINGS HE NEEDS TO DO. SO
WHEN HE GOES OUT THERE, HE
DOES THEM RIGHT? IF YOU HAVE A
LESSER COACH THAN ANDY REID,
DO WE SEE REGRESSION? YEAH.
AND, AND THOSE ARE THINGS. I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT OVER THE COURSE
OF THE ARC OF IT BECAUSE
EIGHT BRADY HAD BILL BELICHICK
FOR 20 YEARS
AND MAYBE
MAYBE MAHOMES GOING TO HAVE
ANDY REID FOR 20 YEARS, OR
MAYBE, WHOEVER TAKES EVER FOR
ANDY REID IS GOING TO BE
BASICALLY ANDY REID
2.0. BUT BUT THOSE
ARE THINGS TO BE THINKING
ABOUT
AS WE TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE
THE PROGRESSION IS GOING TO GO
FOR MAHOMES BECAUSE HE STARTS
OFF AT THE TOP.
DO YOU STAY AT THE
TOP OR DO YOU BEGIN TO SLIDE?
YOU KNOW, IS IT THE RUSSELL
WILSON DYNAMIC
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO?
ARTSY AND OTHER GUYS POP INTO
THE NFL
THAT
THAT MAY CHALLENGE
MAHOMES. WELL, IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE GUYS WHO'S
ALREADY HERE. IT'S GOING TO BE
A GUY WHO'S CURRENTLY IN HIGH
SCHOOL THAT ENDS UP BEING
BETTER THAN MAHOMES, NOT THAT
A HOMES DIPS. YES, SOMEBODY
SHOWS UP. WHO'S BELLE? I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THIS. WE'VE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION A LOT. IT JUST,
YOU KNOW, THE GREAT. IT'S THE
GREATEST SPORT IN OUR COUNTRY
IS THE MOST POPULAR THE
GREATEST ATHLETES WANT TO PLAY
QUARTERBACK,
YOU KNOW, I, WE'VE SEEN IT A
LITTLE BIT, THE BRETT FAVRE TO
THE AARON RODGERS TO THE
MAHOMES, AND NOW WE'RE SEEING
JOSH ALLEN AND WE'RE
SEEING THESE GUYS,
EVERY YEAR THEY CAN COME OUT
AND DO KIND OF THESE CRAZY
TYPE OF THINGS WITH THE
FOOTBALL. SO I WOULD EXPECT.
YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO SEE THIS. WE SHOWED THAT
CLIP A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT KID
DOWN IN HIGH SCHOOL. THE TEXAS
HIGH SCHOOL QUARTERBACK WAS
GOING TO OHIO STATE.
I MEAN, DAMN, HE'S THROWING
THE BALL LIKE PATRICK MAHOMES
LIKE LEGITIMATELY LIKE
THROWING THE BALL LIKE PATRICK
POEMS. SAME PACE FAR AS HE
WANTS WHATEVER SO WE
ARE GOING TO SEE THAT THAT IS
THE MAHOMES EFFECT
AND YEAH YOUR POINT ABOUT
YOU KNOW, WILL THEY CONTINUE
LIKE I STILL
THINK AGAIN.
MAHOMES, EVEN WITH AN AVERAGE
CAST OF CHARACTERS IS BRINGING
THEM TO THE PLAYOFFS, IT WOULD
BE LIKE AN AARON RODGERS
TYPE STORY, I DON'T THINK
THEY'LL BE 14 AND
2 OR 15 AND 1 BUT
EVEN WITHOUT A
KELSEY RETIREE KILL,
I STILL THINK HE'D BE,
YOU KNOW, PLAYING AT A REALLY
HIGH LEVEL. I JUST, YEAH, I
DON'T MAYBE SOME OF THESE
GAMES THAT WE GO.
OH, THEY'RE NOT PLAYING THEIR
BEST TODAY, BUT YET THEY STILL
WIN. I DON'T KNOW IF THEY WIN
THOSE. IF THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
CAST OF CHARACTERS
WILL SEE. CAN THEY
REFURBISH THAT
TEAM? YOU KNOW. BRADY GOT
THE
DION.
RANCH, BALANCE RUNNING GAME,
DEFENSE ERA, THEN IT WENT TO
THE,
YOU KNOW, WES WELKER
RANDY MOSS ERA
THAT ENDED, THEN IT WENT TO
THE EDELMAN AND
GRONKOWSKI AND HERNANDEZ ERA
HE HAD A. YEAH, YOU'RE RIGHT.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT
REFURBISH THE TEAM AROUND HIM
ALL THE TIME. SO YOU COULD
CONTINUE TO SEE THE TALENTS OF
BRADY WILL SEE IF THEY CAN DO
THAT WITH MAHOMES. YOU KNOW,
MY THING HERE IN MIKE AND
GO AHEAD. WAIT GO AHEAD. YOU
READY WENT TEN YEARS BETWEEN
SUPER BOWL CHAMPIONSHIPS TO
YES
AND YEAR? I KNOW,
I KNOW.
AND THAT'S WHERE I DON'T KNOW.
LIKE, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD. I
THINK IT'S GOING TO BE HARD
FOR SOME OF THESE YOUNG CROP
OF
QUARTERBACKS WHO PLAY A STYLE
LIKE AN AARON RODGERS,
BUT, YOU KNOW, BROKEN
COLLARBONE AND THINGS LIKE
THAT.
YOU KNOW, MAHOMES IS FOOT.
WE SAW, JOSH ALAN,
ALLEN, AVOID
LITTLE. HEY, WHEN YOU PLAY
THAT WAY,
YEAH, YOU'RE GOING TO, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET HIT MORE, YOUR
BODY'S GOING TO GET, PUT IN
VULNERABLE POSITIONS AND
THE LONGEST. WE GOT A GUY.